you have worked with some of the best
animation studios out there between
illumination and leica so can you tell
me something that both do when you work
with them that you really appreciated
and then something that made each of the
experiences unique
the amount
of patient
pre-production
the amount because when you when you
you go to record
a first round
uh voice recordings you if they like it
you start to draw it out and sketch it
and then
they're going back and seeing how the
story works and sometimes i'll come back
and re-record a whole different scene
because they go we saw how the story
played out and that scene didn't work we
want to rewrite it so
the amount of patience before they
actually go to the
locket let's finally go to animation
let's really make it come to life on the
screen
uh is a
it's a lot longer time than the live
action film um and they're building it
they're building the film more so
in the while you're recording in
production than you do in live action
speaking of buster in particular he's
one of my favorite characters in these
two movies because i love the fact that
he's someone that is yeah living his own
dream but also he's basically there to
help others live their dreams so do you
have any examples over the course of
your career of someone who stepped in
and helped you live your dream at just
the right moment right when you needed
it
late great friend don phillips who just
passed away last week he's the guy i met
in the bar in austin texas who
cast me in days confused my very first
film he's the guy whose couch i slept on
for four months for nothing he's the guy
who
you know when i said i i gotta go meet
an agent
he's a guy who said
not yet
you're too needy
if they smell you they smell your need
you're out the door he was right um he's
a guy who got not only get me
my first chance he gave a lot of great
actors um they're they're their first
chance and he was a he was a great uh
role model and mentor for me just
listening to your howard stern interview
i'm a big dazed and confused fan so i
like those stories
um
speaking of your animation experience in
recent years is there anything about
doing work where you're hyper focused on
your voice work that you find
influencing your live action work now
yeah you remind you to be less conscious
less self-conscious because you can go
in you cannot screw up doing voice work
try and screw up you can't
say it in spanish say it in english say
it backwards say it forward saying hi
pitch say in a low pitch sing it wrap it
whatever you can't screw up it's all
what are you losing the tape's rolling
the audio tape shirling so what
to take that lack of self-confidence
back to the live action
because
the truth is
even in live action where you have the
visuals well
you can't screw up try it what's it
matter
doesn't
do it again
i like that outlook on it encourages you
to play around a little yeah um speaking
about what buster goes through in this
movie if you had the opportunity to kind
of pull a buster in sing too make the
movie or show of your dreams where
resources didn't matter what would that
production be where resources didn't
matter well there's a great thing where
resources don't matter what do you do do
you if you got you know if you got
14
trillion dollars to do it what do you do
do you do one for do you one thing for
14 trillion or do you do
14 million things make it through that
way that is a very smart play though do
you take a couple zeros off and do 14
million of those same things um
there's a i i
my my creative mind doesn't uh
necessarily go to
oh if i had more resources or more money
this is what i would do i'm really heavy
on
script
and a word
doesn't cost anything if it's written
well and that that scripts really well
i'm for
something being able to be entertaining
and educational enlightening if it's
just you and i right here saying it back
and forth now we can go well let's put
let's build the scenes around this
written word that's really good let's
cast this right away let's say what is
our story what's our journey so we can
have some dynamic in the storytelling
but i want it to work just as a written
word
first and that doesn't cost
anything when it's time to go into
production with that mentality i'm going
to pray you get a buster and you can
make millions of those little
productions and then i can enjoy them i
like scale thank you very much
you